Freunde herzlich willkommen aus München
der bayerischen Landeshauptstadt wir
sind heute hier um einen Tag lang alles
zu essen was uns in die Hände kommt und
ich sage euch so viel da wird vieles
dabei sein von Klassikern zu Geheimtipps
wir haben jetzt mittlerweile wieder
wunderschönes Wetter einiges erlebt und
ich bin ready los geht's
[Musik]
wir haben einen langen Tag vor uns ich
brauche Koffein und nicht irgendwie ich
brauche hochqualitatives Koffein deshalb
sind wir hier vor Sweet Spot eines
speziality coffe geladen glaube ich
gönnen Flat white doppelter Espresso
rein in die Birne und dann habe ich
genug Power für den Tag heute mal gucken
was Sie sonst noch so haben Laden
gefällt mir von außen schon mal sehr gut
[Musik]
wie kann man einen Tag besser starten
das mit einem guten Kaffee und einer
kleinen Süßigkeit Leute wir sind in
München wir testen die Fußball richtig
was vor heute und ich sage euch so viel
dieser Kaffee kann sich sehen lassen
[Musik]
morgen ganz ehrlich kann der Tag
anfangen und das hier ist eine
Besonderheit die haben wenige kleine
Backwaren dazu das ist ein unfassbar
weiches Brioche welches mit einer
Marmelade gefüllt ist habe ich so noch
nie gesehen hat uns direkt angelacht
eigentlich wollten wir nur den Kaffee
essen aber dass sie zu brutal aus
deshalb lass uns das ganze testen alter
Schwede das ist so weich so warm
das ist eine Fusion aus so einem
italienischen kornetto die gibt's ja mit
dieser
Aprikosenmarmelade im Brioche Zopf und
in Berliner das ist so wirklich so
besser aus drei Welten unglaublich gut
ganz ehrlich Leute guter Kaffee nette
Kleinigkeit so kann man den Tag starten
das war's auch schon vom ersten Spot
Sweet Spot Kaffee wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Jahr kurzer schaut euch an
Timon Breaking Bad Teller der saß gerade
eben auch im Café hat einen Kaffee
Channel also alles rund um Kaffee der
prüft das also vertraut mir der Kaffee
ist richtig gut weiter geht's zum
viktualakt
ein Ort an dem es viele Köstlichkeiten
gibt und noch viel mehr wir haben Stände
an den es Honig gibt es Gemüse
eingelegte Gurken es gibt wirklich alles
und hinter mir ist der kleine
ochsenbrater den habe ich hier zufällig
entdeckt da gibt es Weißwurst da gibt's
Brezen natürlich müssen wir eine
Weißwurst Essen Attacke gehen wir rein
das ist uns gut schmecken
[Musik]
einmal die zwei Weißwürste mit Brezen
und ein weizenbegriff fertig
ich glaube jetzt sind wir offiziell da
das zweite Frühstück Kaffee haben wir
drin weißwurstbrezel sind die besten in
München weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube
in diesem Setting hier auf dem
Viktualienmarkt auf jeden Fall ganz
besonders wahrscheinlich kriegt man
überall eine gute Weißwurst oder eine
vernünftige Weißwurst eine gute Breze
findet man auch aber das einfach was
Besonderes hier zu sitzen bei Fußball
geht ja nicht nur darum die allerbesten
zu zeigen sondern schöne Erfahrung gehen
wir rein in die Weißwurst ich werde
jetzt nicht ganz klassisch putzen zum
einen weil ich nicht kann zum anderen
weil ich sie nicht aussaugen möchte ich
mache das immer so klassischer
mittelschnitt hier vielleicht ist das
schon illegal was hier gerade machen
vielleicht wird man dafür in München
verhaftet und halbiere immer so einmal
zack vierteln und raus damit ein
bisschen süßer Senf drauf
heute ist wenn wir das machen dann
richtig
das ist touristisch aber es ist auch
geil
dafür am Viktualienmarkt Sommer
Biergarten 10:41 Uhr ein Bier trinken
[Musik]
Freunde an so einem Tag wie heute ist
natürlich auch sportlicher Ausgleich
wichtig und genauso wichtig mindestens
genauso wichtig ist es ausreichend zu
trinken idealerweise Wasser und am
besten mit Geschmack deshalb habe ich
natürlich meine erbflasche mit dabei und
ich weiß was ihr euch denkt dass da
hinten ist ein Baum das hier ist eine
Wiese ich bin ein Mensch aber das hier
ist keine normale Wasserflasche sondern
eine besondere Flasche denn wenn ich
immer den Deckel öffne seht ihr ja wir
können daraus trinken aber das
eigentliche Ereignis wird ausgelöst wenn
ich den Ports hier und
Geschmack in meinem Rachen ankommt es
ist jedes Mal wieder überraschend Retro
nasales riechen heißt das Ganze dadurch
dass ich den Pott anhebe kann Luft um
den Pott zirkulieren und meinem Gehirn
wird suggeriert ich trinke gerade etwas
mit Flüssigkeit in der Flasche ist
allerdings ganz normales Wasser und
glaub mir wenn ich sage das ganze
funktioniert wirklich und es stimmt auch
wirklich dass ich dadurch mehr trinke
das ist kein Spaß normalerweise sitze
ich gerne warum es manchmal einfach Spaß
daran zu trinken und langweilig wird es
auch nicht weil es gibt verdammt viele
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen egal
ob Cassis guava oder Basil Lemon ist es
auf jeden Fall für jeden was dabei es
gibt aber auch Erdbeer Balsamico oder
Gurke also es ist wirklich für jeden was
dabei ihr könnt euch eure Flaschen nach
Belieben zusammenstellen eine Flasche
mit bunten Deckel wählen oder wie ich
die stilbeutel wenn ihr jetzt Lust auf
mehr bekommen habt dann checkt er ab ab
in der Videobeschreibung ist ein Link
und unten ist auch ein QR Code
eingeblendet deshalb einfach mal
vorbeischauen macht euch schlau vielen
lieben Dank an ihr habt das den Kanal
schon so lange unterstützen ohne Witz
die machen sehr viel möglich auch solche
Reisen deshalb Kuss und weiter mit dem
nächsten Fußball
[Musik]
wir sind vom Mama Bau einem absoluten
Geheimtipp den ich von vielen Leuten von
Freunden von euch Zuschauern und auch
von Locals hier genannt bekommen habe
ist es dann noch ein Geheimtipp ich
glaube schon denn das was wir hier
bekommen gibt es nicht überall uns
erwarten handgezogene Nudeln und
superweiche Bauern also lass uns schnell
reingehen in den wunderschönen Laden
angucken und das Essen genießen schauen
wir mal in die Karte tatsächlich ist
hier der Klassiker bzw der Geheimtipp
nicht das Bauern zu nehmen sondern die
Yang Yang tiefnudels die sind hier der
absolute Bestseller das sind hinter mir
in der Küche von Hand gezogene Nudeln
und das wird wirklich in echtzeitig
gemacht super dünn super breit mit slow
guckt beef ich glaube das ist etwas was
man nicht überall bekommt und etwas was
wir unbedingt testen müssen wenn wir
hier in München sind das ist der
Geheimtipp und die sagen viele kommen
wegen der Nudeln nur zu ihm aber man
will irgendwie auch ein Bauern probieren
wenn man schon hier ist ne deshalb haben
wir beides bestellt gucken wir mal was
uns erwartet
[Musik]
vielen Dank ich verstehe auf jeden Fall
warum das hier der Geheimnis da ist nur
vom angucken starten wir erstmal mit dem
namengeber mit dem Bauern das hier ist
der Topseller habe ich mir sagen lassen
Crispy Chicken baubang ganz einfach das
gedämpfte Bauwagen kommt auch in diesem
Dampfkorb dann haben wir ein bisschen
coldsdorf ein bisschen Karotte
Mayonnaise und unten drunter dieses
panierte Hähnchen Teil ein gutes Bauern
zeichnet sich durch diese himmlische
Konsistenz aus das ist einfach wie eine
Wolke ist wenn man rein weiß und das
teste
wir sehen auf jeden Fall das Bauern an
sich ist auf jeden Fall auch viel größer
als das was wir bei uns bekommen doppelt
so groß kann man sagen
erinnert so ein bisschen Andreas
kommt also die Mario leichte Schärfe das
ist verdammt gut das sind gedämpfte
hefeteigbrötchen und es ist wirklich was
besonderes leckeres wenn jemand die
Möglichkeit haben zu essen oder sogar
hierher zu kommen probiert auf jeden
Fall aus aber jetzt bin ich gespannt auf
den geheimen starten guckt euch das
einfach mal an das sieht aus wie Gulasch
mit dem Stäbchen halte man merkt dass es
wirklich so ich muss probieren
kaum Widerstand beim Kauen unfassbar
zart richtig geschmackvoll und auch so
ein Spice Blend der sehr ungewohnt ist
für mich aber unfassbar gut Nudeln bin
ich auch extrem gespannt weil das sind
einfach so rechteckige teigformen die
dann lang gezogen werden immer noch mal
in der Mitte geteilt werden und so dann
direkt in den Topf kommen also komplett
handmade im Haus man muss ja auch so
mäßig stürfen und dann abweisen
ganz besondere Konsistenz auch wieder so
ein bisschen diese Klebrigkeit eine
wunderschöne Schärfe ich habe mich
verstanden
habe
neue Dinge erleben nicht umsonst habe
ich ja auch in Köln
genommen weil man möchte einfach auch
neue Eindrücke sammeln und dann halt
nicht wieder Burger Pizza zeigen
da war ja noch gar keine Schlange guckt
euch das mal an jetzt ist hier richtig
was los deshalb der Tipp für euch
[Musik]
wir sind bei unserem nächsten Spot der
kleine Flo und kleines Programm denn
hier gibt es mini-burger die sollen sehr
gut sein es wurde mir unfassbar oft
vorgeschlagen deshalb setzen uns auf die
Terrasse und mal gucken was wir
bestellen und das Bestellen funktioniert
hier anders als wir es bisher gewohnt
sind es gibt so eine Karte da wählt man
aus verschiedenen ich glaube insgesamt 1
2 3 4 5 6 aus 18 verschiedenen
minibagger zu schnell rechne wir nehmen
jetzt mal dieses flow-menü groß das sind
drei Minibagger eine Beilage und einen
Dip für 13,90 super fresh und wir nehmen
die Burger wir haben gerade schon
geschaut einmal Cheeseburger um zu
gucken dass der wirklich taugt einmal
die Knoblauch Liebe und Trüffel
speckhändler ich finde es jetzt auf
jeden Fall schon echt nice das Konzept
ist cool dass man verschiedene kleine
Burger probieren kann wenn sie jetzt
halt auch gut sind ne weil man könnte
sich vorstellen wenn es so viele
verschiedene sind leidet die Quali aber
ich glaube so oft wie das empfohlen
wurde ist das richtig gut hier
[Musik]
eine Pracht bietet sich da wir haben
einmal den Classic Cheeseburger beim
Knoblauch Liebe und Trüffel chicken
erstmal Pommes Test ich teste
Süßkartoffeln knusprig in fluffig das
ist ein super fangkonzept ne aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass das nicht die
besten Burger der Welt sind ist
vielleicht aber auch nicht der Anspruch
wir haben ja gerade schon feststellen
können dieser ganze Prozess mit der
Karte
ich habe ein sehr schön Geschmack und
ich verstehe diesen Burger ne das sieht
auch so die Variation das hat sowas wie
Tapas irgendwie so das würde man Burger
mit Tapas kreuzen ich möchte gerne
Knoblauch liebe das sieht so aus als
könnte es extrem knoblauchig werden so
dieses Haus hier glaube ich aber auch
sehr gut
getrockneten Tomaten auch ein bisschen
Salat eingelegtes
macht Spaß zu probieren
und auch der letzte Burger war super
lecker was soll ich sagen es ist
wirklich ein Konzept was Spaß macht man
kann sich durch die Karte testen ist es
der beste Burger den ich je gegessen
habe nein aber es ist ein Ort zu dem ich
auf jeden Fall mit Freunden gehen würde
weil das Essen ist abwechslungsreich und
nice deshalb falls euch anspricht kommt
vorbei falls nein ist der nächste Spot
bestimmt was für euch
weiter geht's mit dem nächsten Spot my
tantuni wir stehen davor tantuni ist
eine türkische Spezialität das ist
gehacktes was in so einer runden Schale
gebraten wird und dann in ein Sandwich
oder in Fladenbrot gewickelt wird sehr
sehr lecker ich kenne ich habe es noch
nicht so oft gegessen aber hier soll es
richtig gutes Tante geben deshalb gehen
wir mal rein und gucken wie es ist
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt also unser
tanturnier und Leute ich muss eins sagen
es sieht verdammt gut aus gucken wir uns
das einfach mal an der perfekte
Zwischenschnitt nicht zu viel Brot
Rinderhack hier unten ein bisschen Salat
ein bisschen Tomate ein bisschen
Petersilie und das ganze wurde mit einer
granatapfelsoße gepfennig dazu gibt es
diese schönen scharfen Chilis perfekt
für mich jetzt mal so ein schöner
orientalische Einfluss noch mal zwischen
den Spots lassen
geile frische geile Würzigkeit schön
aufeinander abgestimmt oder ist von
nichts zu viel oder zu wenig ein richtig
richtig guter Snack und auch mal
wirklich was anderes zwischendurch ich
habe immer euch auf Instagram nach
Vorschlägen gefragt wurde ganz oft
genannt bei den Vorschlägen wenn jemand
welche geben wollt folgt besser mal rein
auf Instagram aber ganz ehrlich das ist
wirklich so perfekt für so ein Tag wo
man schnell Zwischenstopp macht und sich
das hier reingehen
[Musik]
ein kulinarischer Traum von einem Tag
geht zu Ende mit eine Münchner Klassiker
bzw mit ein paar Münchner Klassikern in
einem Brauhaus davon gibt es viele und
ganz viele von euch haben gesagt geh
nicht in die Brauhäuser aber xavas
hinter mir ist dann raus dass ich das
wirkliche kochen und die gute Küche auf
die Fahne geschrieben hat deshalb
bestellen wir uns da ein zwei bayerische
Klassiker und lassen den Abend mit einer
Masse oder mit einer halben ausklicken
los geht's diese Zwiebeln ich glaube ich
habe sie noch nicht gegessen aber ich
glaube das ist eine Beleidigung dass man
diese aus dem Eimer auch Rest Zwiebeln
genau
aber auch das hier werden wir wieder mit
voller Hingabe testen eine
Zwiebelrostbraten kommt einfach mal rein
hier du siehst das ne der ist super dünn
aber trotzdem saftig ich sage euch eins
mit dem Auge erkennt man der ist super
durchgebraten wir probieren kann man
dich machen ich kann kein bayrisch reden
er sollte gut sein er ist teuer aber
besser ihr kommt hierher es ist richtig
vernünftiges bayerisches essen als in
irgendein touristisches Brauhaus zu
gehen und dann ein bisschen weniger zu
bezahlen aber auch eine schlechte
Qualität zu bekommen meine Meinung Cars
Spatzen
wunderschönen cremig perfekte dezente
cremige Note das hat mir gefehlt heute
noch das sagt nach solo Workout nach so
einem Tag als Abschluss krank über 12
Stunden unterwegs gewesen heute in der
Mission gutes Essen zu finden zu testen
und euch zu zeigen und ich kann nur
sagen ich liebe meinen Job deshalb danke
dass ihr zugeschaut habt wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder alles
trotzdem und verlinkt und schreibt mal
in die Kommentare ob ihr den Teil zwei
wollt weil wir haben noch einiges parat
ciao ciao